هي راح تكون من النوع او من الشخصيات اللي
حتكرر
هكذا طريقه الاحتجاج وكما اشرت انه هذه
مستهدفه بهذا التشريع وبالتالي بالمستقبل
حيكون اسهل ضبطها من الناحيه القانونيه
تحت طائله القوانين الجديده الجنائيا
الاحتجاج السلمي طبعا هو ما يقفل به
القانون حقوق الانسان لا تعطي الحق
بالاحتجاج التي الذي من خلاله تستخدم
القوه او العنف او الحاق الاضرار اعتقد
هذا هو الفارق الخط واضح جدا
هذا الالحاق ينتهي عندما يتجاوز اما
التشريعات عاديه او حريات لاخرين وهنا في
بريطانيا اللي بيحصل انه هذه الامور اصبحت
تعدي يعني هم
بكثير من الاحيان يعني
ينظرون الى هذه كاقليه من المحتجين ياخذون
الاحتجاج الى مستوى
غير مسبوق بحيث انه بيستخدموا الطرق
واساليب تكاد تكون عسكريه في طريقتها
وهناك ايضا يعني مجازفه بالطريقه التي
يمارسون فيها حق الاحتجاج وهناك سخب
وصرخات عاليه تزعج
الاخرين وهناك اضرار
للاملاك الخاصه وهذه كلها تعتبر تجاوز على
الخط المحدد للممارسات ممارسه حق التعبير
وممارسه احق الاحتجاج